I have something for you today that I
think you're really going to enjoy
Ivanka Trump Donald Trump's daughter who
is often in positions of power in terms
of being a spokesperson or
representative for the position of the
Trump administration you might remember
is unelected she's not been elected to
anything she's not confirmed by the
Senate she would actually be precluded
from holding an official position
because of anti-nepotism laws she often
sits in official government
conversations she was recently
interviewed by her own spokeswoman a
State Department spokeswoman a complete
and total farce meant to create the
appearance of accountability and of
transparency and of answering questions
from the press imagine if I was in some
kind of scandal it could happen right
and I said I am going to subject myself
to questioning I will be transparent I
am going to explain to you what I did
and why I did it and I will be held to
account and I will let the press talk to
me and then it's like my own staff that
interviews me right you would say what
the hell are you doing how is this
transparency so Ivanka goes to the Doha
Forum in Doha Qatar or Qatar as Tucker
Carlson calls it big announcement that
she would be speaking it's already sort
of like why is she going to be speaking
but okay she's going to be speaking this
immediately created an uproar of
questions what is she doing in Qatar is
this some kind of signal to the royal
family about something of some kind is
Jared Kushner going of course Jared
Kushner's connections to the region are
problematic at best and downright
corrupt at worst
but then she shows up the room is filled
with officials from all over the world
actual officials being interviewed by
real journalists asking actual questions
about policy and issues it's a forum
actually known for tough interviews
Lindsey Graham was there he got into a
whole thing with a real journalist about
impeachment for example the Rwandan
president was asked about term limits
which is an immediate and very real
issue in Rwanda the president there
I believe it's Paul Paul Kagame Kagame
Kagame I believe
so in comes Ivanka Trump to be
interviewed and the interviewer is
Morgan Ortega's that's the same person I
just quoted in the last segment who told
us why the Trump administration is not
going to be recognizing the Armenian
Genocide as a genocide Morgan is the
current State Department spokesperson
and a former Fox News contributor and
she throws Ivanka utter softball
questions for example you were able to
put women's prosperity into the national
security strategy that was so important
to me that you did that and I'd love for
you to explain that whoa transparency
Wow Ivanka is really going to have to
account for oh right it's bogus
speaking of travels you've been in
Morocco recently can you tell us more
about the trip in highlights oh well we
rode camels and I met some business
owners another question you also
returned on a swing through Latin
America with our deputies Deputy
Secretary of State John Sullivan can you
tell us about some of your impressions
oh it's so vibrant and whoa what can
everyone hear that's representing the
private sector do ya that's a really
hard hitting issue and with all of the
successes of the initial launch what are
you doing to ensure that this lasts much
beyond your time in the White House a
Russian journalist said at the event
even Vladimir Putin doesn't get
interviewed by his own press secretary
this is how what are effectively
monarchs this is how monarchs are
groomed right in this case Ivanka sort
of the equivalent to the Queen's
daughter but or even the Queen right I
mean unelected unconformity in
completely over her head this is how you
groom monarchs controlled audiences
controlled questions calculated foe
transparency biased press conferences
with softball questions would never have
a role in government were it not for her
dad
not to mention remember that the Trump
kids said they were going to try to stay
out of politics at the start of Trump's
presidency that ship has obviously long
sail'd she's basically asking herself
questions this is a crafted fake
interview with the spokeswoman that she
traveled there with now here's my
question is this an attempt to look
important like is this an ego thing for
a Vanka Trump is this because she simply
couldn't handle a real serious interview
is this because the people at the State
Department realized that she shouldn't
be there at all and this is how they
protect their own image by making sure
that she doesn't embarrass the State
Department by virtue of being asked real
questions by actual journalists my
question is who do you think decides
that this is what they are going to do
and what is going to be done and at what
point is it decided and for what purpose
let me know by replying if you're
watching on youtube leave a comment or
send me a tweet at D Pakman the next
video is coming soon but before you go
to that please hit subscribe and like
we're running a test we believe that if
everybody does this this will hugely
boost us in YouTube's algorithm and then
everybody wins I'll report back to you
how this works make sure before you go
on to that next video hit subscribe hit
like thank you so much